Bienvenue dans cette série sur la compréhension de l'information et du calcul quantiques. Je m'appelle John Wattress et je suis directeur technique de l'éducation chez IBM
Quantum. C'est la 16e et dernière leçon de la série, et le sujet de cette leçon est le calcul quantique tolérant aux
pannes. Au cours des trois leçons précédentes, nous avons vu plusieurs exemples de codes de correction d'erreurs quantiques qui peuvent détecter et nous permettre de
corriger les erreurs quantiques, à condition qu'il n'y en ait pas trop. Si on veut utiliser la correction d'erreurs pour le calcul quantique, il reste cependant encore de nombreux
problèmes à résoudre, notamment le fait que nos quantum gates, mesures et préparations d'états
sont elles-mêmes susceptibles d'être imparfaites. Ainsi, par exemple, si on va effectuer une correction d'erreurs sur un
ou plusieurs qubits encodés à l'aide d'un code de correction d'erreurs quantiques, on devra le faire avec des gates et des mesures qui elles-mêmes
ont une chance de ne pas fonctionner correctement. Et cela signifie non seulement qu'on risque de ne pas détecter ou corriger les erreurs, mais aussi possiblement
d'en introduire de nouvelles. De plus, on doit également effectuer les calculs qui nous intéressent, là encore avec des gates qui ne sont pas
parfaites. Et on ne peut certainement pas prendre le risque de décoder l'information quantique pour effectuer des calculs, puis de
la ré-encoder une fois terminé, car des erreurs pourraient survenir lorsque la protection d'un code de correction d'erreurs quantiques est absente.
Cela signifie qu'on doit trouver comment effectuer des quantum gates directement sur des qubits logiques qui ne se retrouvent jamais sans la
protection d'un code de correction d'erreurs quantiques. C'est une mission difficile, mais il est établi que tant que le niveau de bruit
reste en dessous d'une certaine valeur seuil, il est en fait possible d'effectuer des calculs quantiques arbitrairement grands de manière fiable en utilisant du matériel bruité, du moins
en théorie. Nous aborderons ce fait d'une importance capitale plus tard dans la leçon. Voici un bref aperçu de la
leçon. Nous commencerons par un modèle de base pour le calcul quantique tolérant aux pannes, avec une courte discussion
sur les modèles de bruit, ainsi qu'une méthodologie générale pour implémenter un quantum circuit de manière tolérante aux
pannes. Nous aborderons ensuite la question de la propagation des erreurs dans les quantum circuits tolérants aux pannes et comment la
contrôler. En particulier, je vais discuter des implémentations de gates transversales qui offrent un moyen très simple de contrôler la propagation des
erreurs. Bien qu'il existe une limitation fondamentale qui nous empêche d'utiliser cette méthode
exclusivement. Je parlerai aussi d'une méthodologie différente impliquant ce qu'on appelle les magic states, qui offre une autre approche pour contrôler la propagation des
erreurs dans les quantum circuits tolérants aux pannes. Bien que ce ne soit pas la seule méthode connue, et enfin la leçon
se conclut par une discussion assez générale du théorème de seuil auquel j'ai fait allusion il y a un instant.
Ce théorème stipule que des quantum circuits arbitrairement grands peuvent être implémentés de manière fiable tant que le taux d'erreur de tous les composants
impliqués reste en dessous d'une certaine valeur seuil finie. En général, cette valeur seuil
dépend du code de correction d'erreurs qu'on utilise, ainsi que des choix spécifiques qu'on fait pour les implémentations tolérantes aux pannes des
quantum gates et des mesures, mais pas de la taille du circuit implémenté. Et cela nous donne de bonnes raisons de croire que les
calculs quantiques à grande échelle deviendront un jour réalité. Nous allons commencer par discuter d'un modèle de base pour le calcul quantique tolérant aux
pannes, qui repose naturellement sur des quantum circuits et des codes de correction d'erreurs quantiques. Pour les besoins de cette discussion,
imaginons qu'on dispose d'un quantum circuit qu'on espère implémenter, comme celui montré ici. Il s'agit
d'un circuit de téléportation incluant la préparation de l'EBIT. Mais les détails n'ont pas vraiment d'importance pour cette discussion. Tu pourrais imaginer que
c'est n'importe quel autre quantum circuit, peut-être un circuit bien plus grand qui inclut des préparations d'états, des opérations unitaires
et des mesures. Ce circuit représente bien sûr un idéal, et une
implémentation réelle de celui-ci ne sera pas parfaite. La question naturelle à se poser est : qu'est-ce qui pourrait mal se
passer ? Eh bien, beaucoup de choses pourraient mal se passer. Par exemple, les initialisations d'état ne seront généralement pas
parfaites. Bien sûr, les gates unitaires ne seront pas parfaites, pas plus que les
mesures. De plus, les qubits eux-mêmes seront susceptibles au bruit, y compris la décohérence, à chaque instant
du calcul, même lorsque rien ne leur arrive et qu'ils stockent simplement de l'information quantique. En d'autres termes, à peu près
tout peut mal se passer. Il y a cependant une exception, ou du moins c'est une hypothèse typique :
tout calcul classique impliqué ne sera probablement pas défaillant, car à toutes fins utiles,
les calculs classiques sont essentiellement parfaits. Ainsi, par exemple, si on exécute un algorithme de couplage classique pour
calculer des corrections pour les erreurs du surface code, on n'a vraiment pas à se soucier que ce calcul classique puisse être défaillant. Mais tout ce qui concerne directement
l'information quantique pourrait l'être. Bien sûr, on a besoin d'un modèle précis permettant d'associer
des probabilités aux différentes choses qui pourraient mal se passer. Et si on le voulait, on pourrait élaborer un modèle aussi complexe qu'on le souhaite pour refléter au mieux ce qui
se passe réellement. Cependant, si le modèle est trop complexe, il pourrait s'avérer difficile ou impossible à utiliser ou à
exploiter de manière intéressante. Un exemple très simple de modèle de bruit souvent considéré
est le modèle de bruit stochastique indépendant, où les erreurs ou pannes affectant différents composants à des instants différents,
autrement dit, à des emplacements différents dans le circuit, sont indépendantes.
Par exemple, on pourrait dire que chaque gate échoue avec une certaine probabilité, que des bit flips et des phase flips surviennent sur les qubits stockés avec une probabilité différente
par unité de temps, et ainsi de suite. Mais l'hypothèse est qu'il n'y a aucune corrélation entre les différentes
erreurs. Tu pourrais objecter à ce modèle parce qu'il y aura probablement des corrélations entre les
erreurs. Par exemple, il y a probablement une faible chance d'une erreur catastrophique qui efface tous les qubits d'un coup.
Ou plus vraisemblablement, il pourrait y avoir des erreurs localisées qui affectent néanmoins plusieurs composants.
Personne ne prétend le contraire. Mais néanmoins, ce modèle représente une base simple qui, en
essence, traduit l'idée que la nature est imprévisible, mais qu'elle n'est pas malveillante et ne cherche pas intentionnellement à
ruiner les calculs quantiques. Il existe d'autres modèles de bruit, sans doute plus réalistes, qui sont souvent considérés. Et quel que soit le
modèle qu'on choisit, s'il s'avère que notre modèle nous induit en erreur et qu'on apprend quelque chose de nouveau sur les erreurs dans
le système sur lequel on travaille, on peut naturellement formuler et envisager différents modèles d'erreurs. Ensuite, nous allons
examiner une stratégie de base pour implémenter des quantum circuits de manière tolérante aux pannes. Considérons donc un
quantum circuit logique donné, c'est-à-dire un quantum circuit idéal qu'on souhaite exécuter. Par exemple, on pourrait considérer le même circuit que
précédemment, qui est maintenant un peu étiré parce qu'on va avoir besoin d'un peu plus d'espace pour l'implémentation tolérante aux pannes de celui-ci. Premièrement,
WEBVTT
les préparations d'états, les gates unitaires et les mesures ne seront pas effectuées directement comme des gates simples ou comme
des mesures ou préparations d'états sur un seul qubit, mais seront plutôt réalisées par ce qu'on appelle des gadgets, qui
peuvent chacun impliquer plusieurs qubits et plusieurs opérations. Dans ce diagramme, j'ai
illustré cela en dessinant des cadres violets autour de ces éléments. Tu peux penser à ces cadres violets comme à de petits circuits ou opérations qui sont
simplement étiquetés par la préparation d'état ou la gate qu'on a l'intention d'implémenter. Deuxièmement, on doit protéger
les qubits à l'aide d'un code correcteur d'erreurs. Ce ne seront donc pas les qubits logiques eux-mêmes qui relient ces différents gadgets, mais plutôt les gadgets agissent sur
les qubits physiques qui encodent ces qubits logiques. Et il vaut la peine de souligner ici que les qubits logiques qui nous intéressent
ne sont jamais exposés, ce qui signifie que ces qubits logiques passeront toute leur vie à être protégés par le
code de correction d'erreurs quantiques qu'on utilise. Et enfin, on effectue la correction d'erreurs sur nos qubits encodés
de manière répétée tout au long du calcul, essentiellement chaque fois qu'on en a l'occasion. Et il est absolument essentiel qu'on le
fasse. Intuitivement, à mesure que des erreurs se produisent, le caractère aléatoire ou l'incertitude commence à s'accumuler dans l'état de nos
qubits et on doit constamment travailler à éliminer ce caractère aléatoire ou cette entropie. Et cela se produit grâce à la correction d'erreurs.
On peut donc un peu penser à ces étapes de correction d'erreurs comme à de petits réfrigérateurs logiques ou pompes à chaleur qui
permettent aux qubits logiques de rester froids pour que le calcul puisse fonctionner correctement.
Une fois tous ces choix effectués, c'est-à-dire la sélection de tous les gadgets ainsi que du code, et en supposant un modèle de bruit particulier, il y a une
question fondamentale qu'on peut se poser : est-ce que ça aide vraiment ? Est-ce qu'on améliore les choses ou
est-ce qu'on les empire ? S'il y a trop de bruit, on pourrait très bien empirer les choses,
tout comme le code de Shore à 9Q empire les choses si la chance d'une erreur est trop élevée.
Mais si le bruit est en dessous d'un certain seuil, alors tout ce travail supplémentaire va nous mener quelque part. Et comme on le discutera vers la fin de la leçon,
des voies s'ouvrent pour réduire davantage l'erreur. Dans cette partie de la leçon, on va discuter de la propagation des erreurs dans les
quantum circuits tolérants aux pannes ayant la structure de base que je viens de décrire. Cela s'avère être une
préoccupation majeure parce que si on ne parvient pas à contrôler la propagation des erreurs, les erreurs vont rapidement dépasser nos efforts de correction
d'erreurs. Mais si on est capable de contrôler la propagation des erreurs, notre code aura bien plus de chances
de suivre le rythme pour que les erreurs puissent être corrigées à un taux suffisamment élevé pour que nos calculs
fonctionnent. Le point de départ de cette discussion est la réalisation que les gates à deux qubits ou à plusieurs qubits plus
généralement peuvent propager des erreurs même lorsqu'elles fonctionnent correctement.
Par exemple, considérons une gate C not. Et supposons qu'une erreur X se produise sur le qubit de contrôle avant que la gate C not
ne soit effectuée. Eh bien, une erreur X fonctionne comme une gate X. Et on trouve que
le circuit de gauche est équivalent à celui de droite où des erreurs X se produisent sur les deux qubits après le C
not. C'est une propagation d'erreurs parce que l'emplacement malheureux de l'erreur X à gauche la transforme effectivement en
deux erreurs X à droite. Et on n'y échappera jamais. Tant qu'on utilise des gates C not, il y aura toujours
une chance qu'une erreur X se produise sur le qubit de contrôle juste avant, qui se propage ensuite en deux erreurs X
après. Mais comme on le verra, tant qu'on prend des mesures pour limiter les dégâts que cela cause, ça ira. Et au fait,
le même phénomène se produit quand on a une erreur Z sur le qubit cible juste avant un C not. Et on en a discuté
plus tôt et tu peux vérifier ces égalités en effectuant simplement les multiplications ou tu peux les vérifier en utilisant
Qiskit. Le résultat est que cela causera dans les deux cas des erreurs corrélées sur plusieurs qubits. Et bien sûr, on ne
doit pas oublier que les gates C not elles-mêmes pourraient aussi être défaillantes, ce qui peut également causer des erreurs
corrélées. S'ajoutant à nos préoccupations, les gates à deux qubits suivantes pourraient propager ces erreurs encore plus loin.
Par exemple, si on a trois gates C not comme ici, comme on en trouve quand on mesure les générateurs X-stabilisateurs, par exemple, une seule erreur peut
rapidement se propager à plusieurs qubits. Et si cela se produit dans un seul bloc de code, par exemple, c'est-à-dire un ensemble de
qubits qui encodent ensemble un qubit logique, le code correcteur d'erreurs qu'on a choisi ne va pas s'en sortir,
car les codes sont conçus pour corriger des erreurs de faible poids, pas des erreurs de poids élevé comme celle-ci.
C'est donc quelque chose qu'on doit garder à l'esprit en priorité lorsqu'on réfléchit aux gadgets et aux
étapes de correction d'erreurs dans les quantum circuits tolérants aux pannes. La façon la plus simple connue d'atténuer la propagation des erreurs dans les
quantum circuits tolérants aux pannes est d'implémenter les gates de manière transversale, et j'expliquerai ce que ça signifie
dans un instant. Gardons donc la figure de notre implémentation de circuit tolérant aux pannes à l'écran comme aide visuelle.
L'idée ici est que pour certains codes de correction d'erreurs quantiques, certaines gates peuvent être implémentées de manière transversale, ce qui
signifie les implémenter à l'aide de gadgets qui sont des produits tensoriels d'opérations où chaque opération n'agit que sur un
seul emplacement de qubit dans chaque bloc de code. C'est plus facile à expliquer à travers des exemples. Le premier et
sans doute le plus simple est l'implémentation transversale des gates de Pauli.
L'idée est qu'on aimerait construire des gadgets pour chacune des gates de notre circuit. Et dans tous les cas, ces gadgets
opèrent sur des blocs de code comme on le voit pour les gates X et Z à la fin de notre circuit de téléportation. Bien sûr, on ne peut
pas décoder, appliquer une gate de Pauli, puis ré-encoder car cela laisserait un qubit logique non protégé et des erreurs
pourraient se propager dans le bloc de code suite au ré-encodage.
Heureusement, on n'a pas besoin de faire ça tant qu'on utilise un code stabilisateur, car chaque code stabilisateur permet d'appliquer des opérations
de Pauli directement sur nos qubits logiques. Et en fait, on peut le faire avec un produit tensoriel de gates de Pauli
sur les qubits physiques utilisés pour l'encodage.
Par exemple, si on considère le surface code 3x3 qui est apparu à la fin de la leçon précédente, on peut implémenter les gates X et Z sur le qubit logique
encodé par ce code en combinant par produit tensoriel des gates X et Z avec des gates identité selon les schémas qui sont
suggérés ici. C'est une implémentation transversale de ces gates parce que chacune de ces opérations de gate individuelles
n'agit que sur un seul emplacement de qubit dans chaque bloc de code.
WEBVTT
On n'utilise ici que des gates à qubit unique, donc c'est un peu trivial d'une certaine façon, mais en tout cas, des gadgets comme celui-ci ne vont pas causer de propagation d'erreurs.
Maintenant, n'importe laquelle des gates individuelles dans un gadget comme celui-ci pourrait échouer, et cela introduira
des erreurs, mais on effectuera toujours la correction d'erreurs immédiatement après chaque gadget. Et tant que le taux d'erreur est
suffisamment faible, le code correcteur d'erreurs corrigera ces erreurs.
Et comme je l'ai dit, c'est toujours possible pour les gates de Pauli pour chaque code stabilisateur.
Bien que tu doives identifier le bon schéma de gates de Pauli dans les gadgets pour implémenter correctement l'opération de Pauli logique souhaitée.
Pour un autre exemple qui implique des gates à deux qubits, cette fois on peut considérer les implémentations transversales
des gates C not. En particulier, pour tout code CSS, on peut toujours implémenter une gate C not
entre deux qubits logiques en effectuant simplement des gates C not sur les paires correspondantes de qubits
physiques. Et cela satisfait la condition d'être transversal parce que chacune de ces gates C not individuelles n'agit que
sur un seul emplacement de qubit dans chaque bloc de code. Par exemple, la première gate C not n'agit que sur le qubit le plus haut
dans chaque bloc de code, la deuxième gate C not n'agit que sur le deuxième qubit en partant du haut, et ainsi
de suite. Dans ce cas, on pourrait avoir une propagation d'erreurs parce que les gates C not propagent les erreurs et il n'y a pas
moyen d'empêcher ça. Mais l'essentiel est que la propagation des erreurs ne se produit jamais à l'intérieur d'un seul bloc de code. Par exemple,
une erreur X pourrait se produire sur le qubit du haut du bloc de code supérieur juste avant que le gadget ne soit exécuté, et la première gate C not
dans le gadget va propager cette erreur vers le qubit du haut dans le bloc inférieur. Mais les deux erreurs résultantes sont
maintenant dans des blocs de code séparés. Donc les étapes de correction d'erreurs qui ont lieu après le gadget seront capables de corriger ces erreurs individuellement parce que ces
erreurs n'affectent qu'un seul qubit dans chaque bloc de code.
En revanche, si la propagation des erreurs se produisait à l'intérieur du même bloc de code, on pourrait avoir un problème car la
propagation des erreurs transformerait alors une erreur de faible poids en une erreur de poids plus élevé que notre code ne peut peut-être pas gérer.
Cette implémentation ne fonctionne pas pour les codes non-CSS, mais tant qu'on utilise un code CSS, on peut toujours implémenter des gates C not
de manière transversale. Et pour un exemple de plus, toute
gate de Clifford peut être implémentée de manière transversale pour le code de Steane. Et en fait pour tout color code, ce qui est l'une des vraiment belles choses à propos des color
codes : en particulier, une gate Hadamard sur un qubit logique peut être implémentée en effectuant des gates Hadamard individuellement sur
chacun des qubits physiques, et une gate S logique peut être implémentée non pas par une gate S sur chaque qubit, mais plutôt par une
gate S dagger sur chaque qubit physique. Le résultat est donc que les implémentations transversales de gates sont intrinsèquement
tolérantes aux pannes parce qu'elles ne propagent jamais les erreurs à l'intérieur d'un seul bloc de code, ce qui donne aux étapes de correction d'erreurs une chance de corriger
toutes les erreurs introduites ou propagées par les gates utilisées pour ces gadgets. C'est très bien et c'est une
façon vraiment simple de construire des gadgets tolérants aux pannes, et il y a différents codes qui permettent des implémentations transversales de différentes gates telles
que les gates T, mais malheureusement il est impossible pour tout code non trivial d'implémenter un
ensemble universel de gates de manière transversale, ce qui est un fait connu sous le nom de théorème d'Eastin-Knill. En termes plus techniques, ce qu'il
dit c'est que tant que notre code a une distance d'au moins deux, l'ensemble des gates pouvant être implémentées de manière transversale générera nécessairement un
ensemble discret d'opérations à une phase globale près, et donc cet ensemble n'est pas universel car les ensembles de gates universels
génèrent nécessairement une infinité d'opérations. Je n'expliquerai pas la preuve de ce théorème qui utilise certains
faits de base sur les groupes et algèbres de Lie, qui ne sont pas des prérequis pour cette série. Mais l'idée de base est
que les familles infinies d'opérations transversales ne peuvent pas rester dans l'espace de code parce que de minuscules
différences dans les opérations transversales sont bien approchées par des opérations de Pauli de faible poids que le code détecte comme
des erreurs. On est donc très contents quand on peut implémenter des gates de manière transversale. Mais quel que soit le code qu'on choisit, on sait qu'on aura
toujours des gates qu'on ne peut pas implémenter de cette façon. On doit donc chercher des gadgets alternatifs. Par le
théorème d'Eastin-Knill, on sait qu'il n'est pas possible d'implémenter un ensemble universel de quantum gates de manière transversale, même
pour un code de correction d'erreurs quantiques de distance 2 seulement. On doit donc trouver d'autres façons d'implémenter des gates de manière tolérante aux
pannes, du moins pour certaines gates. Une façon bien connue de le faire est d'utiliser ce qu'on appelle les
magic states. Pour les besoins de cette discussion, rappelons les gates S et T qui sont
des gates à qubit unique définies comme indiqué ici à l'écran. Observons également que premièrement, S est une opération de Clifford,
ce qui découle de notre définition des opérations de Clifford. Mais tu peux aussi vérifier que la conjugaison d'une matrice de Pauli par S nous donne toujours plus ou moins une autre
matrice de Pauli. Et deuxièmement, T n'est pas une opération de Clifford. Et en fait, si on combine T avec Hadamard et C not, qui sont tous les deux
des opérations de Clifford, on obtient un ensemble universel de quantum gates. On ne peut donc pas implémenter une gate T
en utilisant uniquement des opérations de Clifford et des mesures en base standard. Mais on peut en fait implémenter une gate T en utilisant
des opérations de Clifford et des mesures en base standard si en plus on dispose d'une copie de l'état montré ici à
l'écran, qui est la gate T appliquée à un état plus.
Cet état est appelé un magic state, bien qu'il ne soit pas le seul dans cette catégorie.
Le terme magic state est aussi utilisé pour désigner différents états qui jouent un rôle similaire à celui-ci dans les variations de ce
schéma. Par exemple, le circuit montré ici fait le travail. Et ce n'est pas trop difficile à vérifier.
Voici l'état initial avec le système du haut à droite. Et si on applique la gate C not et qu'on simplifie, on obtient l'
état montré ici.
Donc si on mesure le qubit du bas et qu'on obtient un zéro, ce qui se produit avec une probabilité de 1/2, on n'applique pas la
gate S et la sortie est T appliqué à s.
Et si on mesure un, ce qui se produit aussi avec une probabilité de 1/2 bien sûr, on applique bien la gate S et le résultat net est
que la sortie est à nouveau T appliqué à s. Ce n'est d'ailleurs pas la seule façon de faire ça. Il existe d'autres circuits similaires
qui accomplissent la même tâche, mais c'est l'une des façons de le faire.
C'est un exemple quelque peu simplifié de ce qu'on appelle la téléportation de gate quantique, à laquelle j'ai fait allusion dans la leçon 4, où la téléportation est utilisée
WEBVTT
non pas pour envoyer des qubits, mais pour appliquer des gates. Le lien avec la téléportation n'est peut-être pas entièrement clair ici parce que, comme je
l'ai dit, c'est une version simplifiée, dont on peut se contenter parce que T est diagonale. Mais si tu veux en
savoir plus, les mots-clés sont : téléportation de gate quantique.
On pourrait aussi faire quelque chose de similaire pour implémenter une gate S, où cette fois les seules gates dont on a besoin sont une gate C not et une gate Z, avec la mesure,
ce qui est utile si on n'a pas d'implémentation transversale d'une gate S. C'est intéressant mais ce n'est pas
entièrement clair que ça aide vraiment. Dans le cas de l'implémentation de la gate T, par exemple, on
parvient à appliquer une gate T à un état d'entrée. Mais pour ce faire, on semble appliquer une gate T à un état plus pour obtenir un
magic state. Et la situation est similaire pour l'implémentation de la gate S. Le point essentiel est qu'on n'a
pas nécessairement besoin de créer d'abord un état plus puis d'appliquer une gate T pour obtenir un magic state. Il y a d'autres façons possibles d'obtenir cet état. Et
en particulier, on peut le faire sans avoir à se soucier de propager des erreurs dans le calcul sur lequel on travaille, parce que les magic states peuvent être créés
séparément. Cela permet une implémentation tolérante aux pannes d'une gate T, comme je vais maintenant le décrire brièvement.
Premièrement, on ne va pas réellement exécuter le simple circuit à deux qubits montré ici, mais on exécutera plutôt ce circuit en utilisant
des qubits encodés dans le code correcteur d'erreurs qu'on utilise pour notre implémentation tolérante aux pannes. Ce qui signifie que les
gates unitaires et les mesures sont effectuées par des gadgets tolérants aux pannes. Et cela signifie qu'on a aussi besoin que nos
magic states soient encodés. Donc tout sera tolérant aux pannes à condition d'obtenir des
magic states encodés. On suppose ici au passage qu'on dispose déjà d'un gadget tolérant aux pannes pour une gate S. Si
on utilisait le code de Steane par exemple, on pourrait simplement implémenter la gate S de manière transversale. Et pour les codes pour lesquels ça ne fonctionne pas, une option est
d'utiliser d'abord ce schéma entier pour implémenter une gate S de manière tolérante aux pannes, puis d'utiliser cette implémentation ici.
Bien que ce ne soit pas la seule option. Mais de toute façon, pour en revenir à l'implémentation, la question importante qui reste est : comment obtient-on des
magic states encodés étant donné qu'on n'a pas encore d'implémentation tolérante aux pannes d'une gate T pour simplifier
la chose ? Et l'idée clé est qu'on peut utiliser un processus probabiliste pour créer des magic states encodés. Et si ça ne
fonctionne pas, c'est pas grave. On peut simplement jeter les tentatives échouées et réessayer.
Et ça ne perturbe pas le calcul qu'on essaie réellement d'effectuer parce que la création des magic states est réalisée
séparément. Une façon typique de procéder est par un processus connu sous le nom de distillation de magic states. Et ça fonctionne comme
ça. On dispose d'un certain circuit appelé distillateur. On entre dans ce distillateur une collection de magic states
bruités, puis on mesure toutes les sorties sauf une. Et si on conditionne sur tous les résultats de mesure étant zéro,
ce qui se produit alors c'est que ce qui sort est un magic state moins bruité, qui peut ensuite être l'un des qubits entrés dans
un autre distillateur. Et le processus continue jusqu'à ce qu'on échoue parce qu'un des résultats de mesure est non nul et qu'on recommence, ou qu'on ait un magic
state d'une qualité suffisamment élevée pour l'utiliser en toute sécurité afin d'implémenter une gate T dans le calcul qui nous intéresse.
Il existe différentes façons connues de construire un distillateur comme celui-ci, mais ils fonctionnent tous de la même façon de base, c'est-à-dire que ce sont des décodeurs pour des codes stabilisateurs,
ce qui signifie qu'ils sont les inverses des circuits d'encodage, ce qui est bien parce que ça signifie que le distillateur peut être une opération de Clifford.
Et enfin, ce processus de distillation se déroule en réalité au niveau du qubit logique. En réalité donc,
tout est fait en utilisant des gadgets pour le distillateur et les mesures. Ce processus doit
commencer quelque part. Mais tant que le taux de bruit n'est pas trop élevé, il est possible de créer des magic states bruités mais suffisamment bons
pour lancer le processus. Par exemple, en appliquant une gate T réelle bruitée à un qubit dans un état plus, puis en
encodant ce qubit. C'était donc une description de très haut niveau, mais j'espère t'avoir donné une idée approximative de comment ça fonctionne.
C'est bien plus compliqué que d'implémenter des gates de manière transversale, mais néanmoins, ça offre un moyen d'implémenter un ensemble universel de quantum
gates de manière tolérante aux pannes, alors que les implémentations transversales de gates seules ne peuvent pas le faire. On affirme parfois
que le coût d'utilisation des magic states pour implémenter des gates de manière tolérante aux pannes serait très élevé,
la grande majorité du travail allant dans la distillation des magic states et l'exécution du calcul réel étant plus
accessoire. Mais c'est en réalité pas si clair et il y a eu des analyses détaillées qui révèlent que cette méthode
pourrait en fait être pratique. Il existe plusieurs autres schémas connus pour implémenter des gates de manière tolérante aux pannes. La déformation de code et le changement de code sont des noms
associés à certains de ces schémas, et de nouvelles façons continuent d'être développées et affinées, mais je ne décrirai pas ces
méthodes dans cette leçon. Il y a une autre question importante concernant les implémentations tolérantes aux pannes des quantum circuits,
et elle concerne les étapes de correction d'erreurs elles-mêmes. Il ne s'agit donc pas d'implémenter des gates. Il s'agit d'effectuer la
correction d'erreurs proprement dite. Le problème est que si on pense aux circuits simples qu'on a
vus pour la première fois dans la leçon 14 pour mesurer les générateurs stabilisateurs basés sur l'estimation de phase, on constate qu'ils ne sont pas
eux-mêmes tolérants aux pannes parce qu'ils pourraient potentiellement causer la propagation d'erreurs à l'intérieur d'un seul bloc de code.
Cela revient à l'idée que tout ce qui implique de l'information quantique est susceptible d'erreurs, y compris les circuits qui sont eux-mêmes censés
corriger des erreurs. Cela semble assez problématique, mais il existe en fait plusieurs solutions connues à ce problème. Je vais en mentionner quelques-unes
seulement, bien que je n'en explique aucune en détail. Et au fait, si tu as l'impression que le calcul quantique tolérant aux pannes est
compliqué et qu'il y a beaucoup de détails à gérer, c'est certainement compréhensible parce que c'est vrai. Il y a beaucoup de pièces en mouvement
ici et mon intention avec cette leçon n'est pas d'expliquer tous les détails mais plutôt de te donner juste une introduction de base à comment tout
ça fonctionne. Une méthode pour la correction d'erreurs quantiques tolérante aux pannes est connue sous le nom de correction d'erreurs de Shor, du nom de Peter
Shor qui a proposé cette méthode en premier. L'idée est d'effectuer chaque mesure de syndrome en utilisant un état dit cat,
qui est la même chose qu'un état GHZ quand on a trois qubits, mais qui peut être généralisé à n'importe quel nombre de qubits correspondant au poids du générateur stabilisateur
qu'on a l'intention de mesurer. En particulier, le circuit montré ici fonctionne pour mesurer un générateur stabilisateur. Et il peut être
montré que cette méthode ne cause pas la propagation d'erreurs à l'intérieur d'un bloc de code.
Elle nécessite de créer l'état cat lui-même. Et pour la faire fonctionner de manière fiable en présence d'erreurs et de gates potentiellement défaillantes, la méthode
nécessite en réalité d'exécuter ces circuits de manière répétée et de faire des inférences sur les endroits où différentes erreurs ont pu se produire au cours du
processus. Une méthode alternative est connue sous le nom de correction d'erreurs de Steane, qui a d'abord été proposée par Andrew Steane, et cette
WEBVTT
méthode fonctionne différemment et ne fonctionne que pour les codes CSS. Dans cette méthode, on n'effectue pas réellement les mesures de syndrome sur les états quantiques encodés
dans le circuit qu'on essaie d'exécuter, mais on propage intentionnellement les erreurs vers un système de travail
puis on mesure ce système et on détecte classiquement les erreurs. Cette figure montre comment faire ça pour les erreurs X, dans ce cas les
qubits de travail sont initialement mis dans un encodage d'un état plus. C'est donc essentiellement une
implémentation transversale d'une gate C not qui ne devrait rien faire parce que la cible est dans un état plus. Mais s'il y a
des erreurs X dans les qubits du haut, elles vont se propager vers le système inférieur et seront détectées. Il y a aussi une méthode similaire pour détecter les erreurs Z,
qui n'est pas montrée ici. Il y a aussi une méthode connexe connue sous le nom de correction d'erreurs de Knill, proposée en premier par Manny Knill,
et elle est basée sur la téléportation plutôt que sur un C not transversal, ce qui lui permet de fonctionner pour des codes stabilisateurs arbitraires
et pas seulement les codes CSS.
La dernière chose que je vais aborder dans cette leçon est un théorème très important connu sous le nom de théorème de seuil. Voici un énoncé quelque peu informel
du théorème. Il dit que si on dispose d'un quantum circuit quelconque ayant n gates, où n peut être aussi grand qu'on le souhaite, alors il est
possible d'implémenter ce circuit avec une grande précision en utilisant un quantum circuit bruité, à condition que le niveau de bruit
soit en dessous d'une certaine valeur seuil indépendante de n. De plus, ce n'est pas trop coûteux,
dans le sens où la taille du quantum circuit bruité requis est de l'ordre de n fois une certaine puissance constante du logarithme de
n. Énoncer le théorème plus formellement nécessite d'être précis sur le modèle de bruit, ce que je ne ferai pas dans cette leçon.
On peut par exemple le prouver pour le modèle de bruit stochastique indépendant que j'ai mentionné plus tôt, où les erreurs se produisent
indépendamment à chaque emplacement possible dans le circuit avec une probabilité strictement inférieure à cette valeur seuil. Mais on peut aussi le
prouver pour des modèles de bruit plus généraux où il peut y avoir des corrélations entre les erreurs. Maintenant, c'est un résultat
théorique et la façon typique de le prouver ne se traduit pas nécessairement par quelque chose qu'on ferait réellement en pratique, mais c'est néanmoins un
théorème très important en termes pratiques. Et la raison en est qu'il dit fondamentalement qu'il n'y a pas de barrière fondamentale à l'exécution de
calculs quantiques en utilisant des composants bruités.
Tant que le taux d'erreur de ces composants est en dessous de cette valeur seuil, ils peuvent être utilisés pour construire des quantum circuits fiables de taille
arbitraire. Une autre façon de le dire est que si le théorème n'était pas vrai, il est difficile d'imaginer que le calcul quantique à grande échelle
devienne jamais réalité. Il y a beaucoup de détails techniques impliqués dans les preuves formelles de ce théorème, que je ne vais pas essayer de
communiquer. Mais je vais essayer d'expliquer l'idée de base à un niveau élevé. Et j'essaierai aussi de connecter vaguement l'idée de base
à ce qu'on pourrait s'attendre à se passer en pratique. Supposons donc que c'est notre circuit. C'est le même circuit dont on
a parlé tout au long de la leçon. Mais là encore, on peut imaginer que notre circuit est significativement plus grand et plus compliqué que ça. On aimerait
implémenter ce circuit, mais tous nos composants sont bruités. Et en supposant qu'on utilise le modèle de bruit stochastique indépendant
juste par simplicité, il y a une certaine probabilité P avec laquelle des erreurs se produisent indépendamment à chaque emplacement possible.
Si le circuit était significativement plus grand que l'inverse de cette probabilité P, on pourrait être assez sûr qu'une
implémentation directe de celui-ci ne fonctionnerait pas correctement. On s'occupe donc de tout pour implémenter le circuit
de manière tolérante aux pannes comme je l'ai décrit jusqu'à présent dans la leçon, et on se pose la question que j'ai soulevée plus tôt : est-ce qu'on améliore les choses
ou est-ce qu'on les empire ? Eh bien, si la probabilité P représentant la probabilité d'erreur pour chacun de nos composants est trop grande, alors
ça ne va pas aider, tout comme le code de Shor à 9Q n'aide pas si la probabilité d'erreur est supérieure à environ 3 et 4/% environ.
En particulier, on a maintenant rendu le circuit plus grand. Donc il y a beaucoup plus d'emplacements où des erreurs pourraient survenir.
Cependant, si P est assez petit, ça va aider. Et ce qu'on fera effectivement c'est réduire la probabilité d'erreur
pour le calcul logique qu'on effectue. Alors réfléchissons à ça avec
un peu plus de détail. Et pour voir les idées principales dans un cadre aussi simple que possible, supposons qu'on utilise le code de Steane à 7 qubits pour la
correction d'erreurs, qui permet la correction d'au plus une erreur par bloc de code. Donc pour qu'une erreur logique
se produise dans le circuit original, on devra avoir au moins deux erreurs tombant dans le même bloc de code pour notre implémentation
tolérante aux pannes.
En gardant à l'esprit qu'il y a beaucoup de façons différentes d'avoir deux erreurs ou plus dans le même bloc de code, on peut soutenir que la probabilité d'une erreur
logique à chaque emplacement dans le circuit original est au plus C * P ^ 2, où C est un nombre qui dépend du code et
des gadgets qu'on utilise. Mais ce qui est crucial, c'est qu'il ne dépend pas de la taille du circuit original.
Donc si P est plus petit que l'inverse de C, ce qui est le nombre qu'on peut prendre comme valeur seuil, alors cela
se traduit par une réduction de l'erreur. Donc notre dur travail pour implémenter le circuit de manière tolérante aux pannes commence à
porter ses fruits. Cependant, ce nouveau taux d'erreur pourrait encore être trop élevé pour que le circuit entier fonctionne correctement. Donc on doit en faire
plus. En pratique, une chose naturelle à faire à ce stade est de choisir un meilleur code et de meilleurs gadgets pour faire baisser le taux d'erreur
à un point où l'implémentation a de bonnes chances de fonctionner.
D'un point de vue théorique, une façon simple d'argumenter que c'est possible est de concaténer. En d'autres termes, on pense
à l'implémentation tolérante aux pannes du circuit original comme un nouveau circuit logique. Et on l'implémente de manière tolérante aux
pannes. Et on fait ça encore et encore autant de fois qu'on en a besoin. Et il s'avère que ça réduit l'erreur
très rapidement. Et c'est comme ça que le théorème de seuil est typiquement prouvé sur papier.
Je vais te donner juste une idée très approximative de comment le taux d'erreur diminue, en laissant de côté les nombreux détails techniques nécessaires pour
prouver cela formellement. On commence avec la probabilité d'erreur P pour nos composants originaux. Et si on implémente le
circuit de manière tolérante aux pannes, l'erreur diminue d'un facteur C * P. Si on traite ensuite notre implémentation tolérante aux
pannes comme un circuit logique et qu'on l'implémente de manière tolérante aux pannes, on obtient une diminution similaire du taux d'erreur. Mais
si on réfléchit au taux d'erreur effectif pour le circuit original, on constate qu'il baisse encore plus parce que maintenant
on remplace le taux d'erreur P par C * P ^ 2 parce que c'est le taux d'erreur effectif après l'implémentation tolérante aux pannes de premier niveau.
Plus précisément, après juste un peu d'algèbre, on constate que l'erreur descend à CP
au cube * P. Et si on le refait, on a maintenant un taux d'erreur de CP ^ 7 * P. Et si
WEBVTT
on continue à faire ça pour un total de K niveaux, on constate que l'erreur diminue doublement exponentiellement en K. Donc on n'a
pas besoin de le faire beaucoup de fois pour rendre le taux d'erreur extrêmement faible.
Pendant ce temps, les circuits grandissent en taille, mais la taille n'augmente que simplement exponentiellement en K parce qu'à chaque
niveau de tolérance aux pannes, la taille de notre circuit croît d'au plus un facteur déterminé par la taille maximale de
nos gadgets. Et quand tout est mis ensemble et qu'un choix approprié pour le nombre
de niveaux de concaténation est fait, on obtient le théorème de seuil. Mais comme je l'ai déjà suggéré, il y a beaucoup de détails nécessaires pour rendre cela formel. Donc
quelle est cette valeur seuil en réalité ? Eh bien, ça dépend du code et des gadgets qu'on
utilise. Pour le code de Steane avec la distillation de magic states, c'est minuscule et probablement peu susceptible d'être atteignable en
pratique. Mais en utilisant des surface codes et des gadgets de pointe, on l'a estimé à environ 1 %. Ce qui n'est
pas mal. Et à mesure que de nouveaux codes et méthodes sont découverts, on peut raisonnablement s'attendre à ce qu'il augmente, tandis que simultanément le
niveau de bruit dans les composants qu'on construit va diminuer. Atteindre le point auquel
les calculs quantiques à grande échelle peuvent être implémentés de manière tolérante aux pannes ne sera pas facile et ça n'arrivera pas du jour au lendemain.
Mais ce théorème, combiné aux avancées dans les codes quantiques et dans le matériel quantique dont on a été témoins à ce jour,
nous donne l'optimisme dont on a besoin pour continuer à avancer vers cet objectif ultime de construire un
ordinateur quantique tolérant aux pannes à grande échelle. Et c'est la fin de la leçon et la fin de la série. J'
espère sincèrement que tu as trouvé de la valeur dans cette série, et si c'est le cas, pense à la recommander à un collègue ou un ami.
Aussi, n'oublie pas de consulter IBM Quantum Learning pour des cours et tutoriels supplémentaires, et abonne-toi à la chaîne YouTube Qiskit
si tu ne l'as pas encore fait, pour rester à jour avec nos futures sorties de contenu. Merci de
nous avoir regardés.